die populisten machen sicher kontinent
weit breit in ungarn werden flüchtlinge
ab sofort internet wie verbrecher
gleichzeitig setzten sich aber auch
stellen geschäft immer mehr menschen für
europa ein junge begeisterte europäer ja
so was gibt der kollegin nico senf haut
zum beispiel ist so ein begeisterter
europäer das stimmt ich bin ich bin
begeisterter europäer ja sag ich doch
außerdem arbeitet der nico als
sogenannter dem motivationstrainer und
er hat für uns eine kleine power point
präsentation vorbereitet genau
ich erkläre jetzt den unterschied
zwischen aufklärern und fanatiker auf
lehrer gehen folgendermaßen an die welt
heran erst gucken sie sich die fakten an
und dann erzählen sie dementsprechend
die geschichte fertig machen genau
umgekehrt bedenken sich erst die
geschichte aus und passen dann alle
fakten der geschichte an
das sind die berühmten alternativen
fakten
gucken uns das jetzt in einem konkreten
beispiel an der aufklärer sieht einen
menschen und stellt fest
der mensch besteht auf unterschiedlichen
eigenschaften er hat zum beispiel
erfahrung religion politische
einstellung psychische gesundheit
soziales umfeld nationalität klar ein
mensch besteht aus unterschiedlichen
facetten
dann kommt der fanatiker und sagt nelson
moslem ein erstes gutes beispiel wie
fanatiker aus einer komplexen situation
eine einfache machen gucken uns das
nächste beispiel an das phänomen
wachsende soziale ungleichheit in den
meisten gesellschaften in westeuropa
geht die schere zwischen arm und reich
immer weiter auseinander woran liegt das
liegt zum beispiel an einen sehr
ungerechten erbrecht an maschinen die
den menschen die arbeitsplätze wegnehmen
lohnkosten die in anderen welt und
niedriger sind
landflucht alternder gesellschaft und
der finanzkrise von 2008 als
lösungsorientierter mensch kann man
sagen wir versuchen an einer dieser
schrauben zu drehen und dann kommt ein
fanatiker und sagt ja oder ausländer
raus und das ist faszinierend weil da ja
gar nicht vorkommen
da sind kreative leistung von uns jetzt
noch das dritte beispiel an in europa
wurde in den letzten jahren darüber
diskutiert wie man amokläufe und
anschläge verhindern kann
auch hier gucken uns einfach mal kurz an
wer waren diese attentäter wir hatten in
den allermeisten fällen folgende
eigenschaften es waren männer
sie gestand waren außenseiter rassisten
mörder unter 50 wie kann man jetzt
attentate künftig verhindern zum
beispiel indem man alle männer unter 50
einfach ins gefängnis wird wer eine
radikale maßnahme aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass es dabei auch
noch anschläge gibt es sehr gering okay
wir es noch mal vernünftig durch männer
unter 50 mörder rassisten außenseiter
wird es wohl immer geben bei den
psychisch kranken könnte man konstruktiv
an setzen und sagen wir versuchen die
versorgung von psychisch kranken zu
verbessern
und da haben dann die populisten in ganz
europa gesagt ja oder wir verbieten
einfach nur krass dass wir ein sehr
vernünftiger vorschlag weil man genau
weiß wenn man sich doch im gesicht hat
dann okay dafür stehe ich auch nicht
besonders spannend hatte ich ja den
beitrag der ard
nach dem amoklauf von münchen hat wenn
er es wir erinnern und da hatte ein
rassist mit migrationshintergrund andere
menschen mit migrationshintergrund
erschossen und da hat dann sogar die ard
gesagt dass es uns zu kompliziert wir
sind raus jetzt bin ich sehr motiviert
sein früherer
[Applaus]